Aaron kena the ultimate rogue of all
rogues has finally been hunted down and
eradicated by the division yet from his
deathbed while taking his last breaths
kena activates what he calls his legacy
so the question remains is this just
another way for him to keep missing with
the shd well after he's gone or is there
a more deep-rooted explanation behind
the rogue agent Network
[Music]
you
a number of months have passed since the
division managed to push back the
hostile factions almost to the brink of
extinction and successfully reclaimed
large parts of the city
Aaron kena had recently returned to the
city of New York and had begun the
process of recruitment for the next
stage in his plans and they also accuse
me of being heartless which I guess
means I'm homeless either that or they
are full of [ __ ] which I consider to be
much more likely still New York when I
come back I honestly don't know maybe
because it's the heart of it all where
this brave new world of ours got started
and I want to stay close to the center
of things
maybe I got tired of seeing the same
crap everywhere else I went there is
nothing
majestic about the aftermath in some
your bedroom community in North Jersey
New York on the other hand there's still
something magic about it even in the
middle of all this it's enough to keep
you coming back James drag off is
brought on board along with his new
family the ruckus initially he was
uninterested in joining his cause
however he quickly changed his mind when
Keena started executing ruckus and
threatened to continue to take them down
until dragged off complied Gina needed
access to the supplies he was able to
acquire and the ability to move them
around the city undetected
following the Sakina approached Theo
panel a master hacker
and tech genius he provided evidence
backing up panels growing suspicions
around his father's death and conveyed
to him that the people higher up had
shown not to have the best intentions of
the people at heart and that the
division was corrupt
with this information he was able to
persuade him to join his side when it
came to Vivian Connelly the newly
appointed leader of the cleaners Keenan
knew that the only way to get her on
board would be through the offering of a
juicy carrot and that carrot came in the
form of the teletran Inca so again he
got his way along with a powerful group
of people now more highly trained and
equipped and they would provide a
valuable distraction in the days to come
and last but not least he brought on a
vehicle chica a powerful mix black ops
government hitmen by providing the names
of those higher up responsible for the
JTF abandoning the quarantine zone which
subsequently led to coach chica having
to choose between his duty as a division
agent in his own life kena was now ready
he had four rogue agents including two
of the largest hostile factions in the
city ready to carry out his plans
via Aaron Kenneth's instructions his new
team of rogues launched a collection of
biological attacks on sites around New
York City
these included City Hall a number of
highly populated areas and an assortment
of JTA facilities and it was this
catalyst that led the acting commander
of the division in New York they allow
to request urgent help from agents in
Washington DC through the use of
surveillance footage Washington agents
quickly established the rogue operatives
were a group of former first wave agents
being led by Aaron keener and this
revelation is what triggered the
citywide manhunt for the infamous rogue
agent undeterred by the divisions search
for him
KYNA continued with his preparations
with panels technological expertise and
drag offs uncanny ability to provide him
with a number of high-tech materials
kinas plans started to become a reality
the rogue agent network was built along
with more lethal forms of his HD tech
and ground-to-air missiles that would
aid in spreading the virus Peter sir
I've made some progress on the network
I'm listening I've got it running in a
test environment right now it's
virtually untraceable
since we're piggybacking off of Isaac's
system he can detect the signal but it's
encrypted until we don't want it to be
what features are we talking here it's
full suite all the benefits without any
drawbacks and scalability in theory it's
unlimited I'm running some simulations
and it's already well beyond our current
needs and we can push out the update
from a single device that's genius
yeah I don't know about all that don't
sell yourself so short you've built an
amazing tool for us with incredibly
limited resources if you like that you
should see what else I got cooking up
and I wish I have the time but you keep
working I look forward to seeing how
this progresses thank you sir
with his plans now in full swing kena
had very little need for his team of
rogue agents anymore and allowed them to
be taken down one by one by the division
they had served their purpose as a
result of the Intel gathered from the
rogue agent watches fail ale was able to
pinpoint Keinath location on Liberty
Island the division agents quickly
boarded a theory and proceeded to kinas
location fail AO also informed the black
tusk of kinas whereabouts and off the
agents enroute to his location as her
loyalties no longer lay with the
division the black tusk quickly launched
a missile attack aimed at the boat and
was successful in destroying it however
the agent survived the black tusk the
insult and ground forces to stop kina
including a Razorback missile launcher
but the division agents were quickly
able to overwhelm their forces throwing
in everything they had left the black
tusk sent into Marauder class quadcopter
and a number of war hounds to kill kina
any remaining agents on the island
akina's knew more advanced shd tech was
able to hack the quadcopter and the war
hounds and he turned them against the
agents the agents were successful in
stopping the hacked forces now that all
black tusk forces on the island had been
eliminated they had no choice but to
abandon the attack leaving kina in the
division agents to finish the fight
fighting through kinas heavy spam of shd
tech the agents eventually cornered him
on the outside at the island where he
was preparing to launch his missiles
containing the new virus but with only
seconds to spare the agents were able to
destroy the missile launcher kina then
launched a head-on attack using a
superior shd tech to push the agents
back however during the attack he was
heavily wounded he managed to escape to
the pier but his injuries proved too
much the division agents caught up to
him and before they could stop him he
activated his rogue agent Network
telling the agents that they have no
idea what is coming
before dying shortly after
so at the stage the rogue agent Network
appears to basically be kinas version of
the shd still it's a little tricky to
know exactly how it works because we're
only just finding out about it through
the rogue agent manhunts that have been
released over time but essentially it
looks like all agents who have had the
connection to Issac severed after going
rogue now have access to this new
network with a new AI called enna
however it's unclear whether these rogue
agents are also been given the more
advanced shd tech like keen ahead though
if I had to guess I would say that this
is the case the few rogue agents we've
come across so far are from the first
wave of division agents released into
New York in Washington DC so it's
possible that these are all agents that
Kira has been in contact with and
possibly the reason why kina
traveled to Washington DC after we first
lost track of him in New York he was
recruited as I discussed in a previous
video there are a number of different
types of rogue agents and not all of
them would have wanted to be involved
and some of them could be working with
the black tusk who want to get rid of
the rogue agents just as badly as the
division does but this may answer one
question it could be the reason that the
rogue agents continue to walk around
with a big red ring on their wrist and
back long before Anna was activated key
Nomis have been planning this so these
agents must have been expecting
something like this for quite some time
it's actually really hard for me to
speculate unless as Aaron kinas
personality shifted so much from the
division one to warlords of New York
this is a generic cleaner reporting it
from dzo to the jcf has pulled out and
are preparing a retreat for manhattan
any agents are still alive know that we
are on our own that's fine
we don't need the JTF whatever we need
the division or the government's
permission to do what has to be done we
were trained for this to complete the
mission against all odds to ensure the
continuity of government to say what
remains but what kind of mission is that
the government doesn't care about us
were expendable sure but they have
carelessly thrown as a sight for no
reason and why should we sacrifice
ourselves for state that doesn't deserve
it we still take a moment to reflect on
that and ask if the mission still stands
me I'm not so sure anymore
at the beginning around the outbreak
kina was highly intelligent and
incredibly sure of himself he also
showed strong determination and
perseverance after turning rogue his
outlook changed as he believed that the
rules and laws that used to govern them
no longer existed and that the only way
to survive is by being the one in
control so as a consequence of this he
began using his abilities in
manipulation and influence push others
into achieving his goals audio logs in
Washington DC showed that he had started
to develop a massive ego and later on
and lower Manhattan a huge superiority
complex was beginning to emerge with an
even greater thirst for power right up
into the point of warlords of New York
Pino was always two steps ahead of the
division yet his final encounter played
out that your typical action movie with
the crazy villain being thought of in
his plans by the unflinching hero and he
was taken down fairly easily the whole
final mission plays out like we caught
him off guard except we didn't he knew
the division was coming and he had
plenty of opportunity to escape remember
he has never had any problems with the
remaining of the division that he is the
smartest person in the room yet to be
caught out on an island with no backup
plan other than to take on the division
face to face doesn't quite fit in with
what we've seen from him up until now
yes there is his legacy as he liked to
call it but did he really need to die in
order to unleash them it's probably fair
to say that keen has certainly looked
rather withered by the time we got to
him perhaps his life on the run finally
got the best of him and he had nothing
more to give I mean they do say that
there's a very fine line between genius
and insanity perhaps he fell over that
line long before we caught up with him
he's trying to save the city by trying
to blow up the city because he feels
that's how to save the city because he
feels betrayed by the government it's
clear that keener has done with Society
he had lost faith in mankind he seemed
to believe that it was his
responsibility to help reset society and
hypothesized that by killing the vast
amount of the population with his virus
only a few would survive due to the
natural immunity and all their ability
to adapt to the new environment
as a consequence of this a new society
would be born this all sounds very
similar to what the creator of the doll
flu had in mind dr. Gordon Amherst
but even then what does the rogue agent
network have to do with any of this
while were they only activated at that
moment as he was dying and what is their
overall goal again it just doesn't seem
very key nourish just to activate them
with the sole purpose of being a general
nuisance this surely must be more to it
or maybe I'm looking at this from the
wrong direction let's go back to the
black tusk for a second this
organization or their employees at least
represents everything that kina stands
against and with president Ellis now on
the payroll and no government to remove
his presidency he still technically the
president so there is the potential
there to Ellis or anyone who could
control Isaac may be capable of marking
all remaining agents as rogue or
alternatively he may declare that the
shd is now deactivated and mark all who
refused to conform as rogues and if any
of this did happen the division would be
severely crippled when they lose access
to Isaac in the network
however because of kinas rogue agent
network they'd be able to continue on as
normal with potentially even more
capability perhaps the activation of the
rope network was only in the situation
that he failed or maybe he realized that
he would need to die in order for the
division to redirected focus on the true
objective up until this point the
division have been investing a lot of
their time in resources into finding
Keena and maybe in order for them to
finally see the big picture he needed to
eliminate himself from the scenario with
kina gone the true enemy would be
revealed he has always been fighting
against the government and any other
organization that mimics the government
ie the black tusk sure what his lift of
the division is a nuisance to kina but
they have never been his main priority
in his eyes they just hadn't yet seen
the light maybe he knew that he would
eventually have to make the ultimate
sacrifice for the people to help the
division on the right path
notice I didn't say killing people is
easy if you think of them as people it
suddenly gets that much harder but if
you simply look at the balance sheet how
much of an obstacle someone is or how
much benefit there is in letting them
keep breathing a while longer
then it becomes simple math and simple
math is simple to do it's almost as easy
as putting two bullets center mass and a
third one in the head
so he gets the question lies was the
rogue agent Network kinas last gift to
the division
I'll be the first to admit there are
other things that still don't quite add
up with that last theory and I'm really
hanging on to that whole Aaron keener is
the hero we all need but don't deserve
spheal but as per usual my main goal
with these sorts of videos is to get
people thinking to open them up to a
different perspective to the
possibilities of where the story could
go to me the warlords of New York
expansion has raised more questions than
it's answered and truth be told that
really don't mind us so probably would
have grown bored of it if the whole
story was just presented to us and full
on a silver platter but what do you
think do you have any crazy theories
around the rogue agent Network let me
know in the comments below or join the
discussion on the discord but before I
go I really must thank my boss manager
and financial advisor aka my wife for
helping woods get another one of these
videos honestly I just come up with
ideas and incoherently throw words at
the screen she's the creative genius who
actually helps them make sense anyway I
think that's enough from me thank you
very much for watching and I'll catch
you in the next one Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]